how is that aund $100 million budget cut
in New York City for for
um schools Library uh police safety and
sanitation yeah Joe Biden is talking
about like yeah we could fund two Wars
New York is already super dirty crimes
are going to go off the rout Roots
because there's there's a there's a a
police safety budget cut judge I love
the fact that this is somebody who
generally is against the police Ione
Brian kill me I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now